I want to know if you agree that each of
these eight developments would have
shocked you not just six months ago but
even six weeks ago these all came in the
last few days and range from text to
video thought to text GPT models
predicting stock moves and AI
Annihilation discussed at Ted but we
start with nvidia's new text to video
model rather than show the paper I'm
just gonna let different examples play
on screen from the paper one of the
breakthroughs here is in temporal
consistency essentially the series of
images that are used to form the video
are more aligned with each other so the
sequence plays more smoothly with fewer
sudden glitches or changes the generated
videos by the way have a resolution of
1280 by 2048 pixels rendered at 24
frames per second and there is a
powerful line from the appendix of the
paper that was released with the samples
the authors say that they expect
enhanced versions of this model to reach
even higher quality potentially being
able to generate videos that appear to
be deceptively real they go on to say
this has important ethical and safety
implications this future might not be
far away as I'm going to show you in a
moment with the progression that has
happened in text image in one year just
before I move on you may have wondered
when this is going to become a product
well they kind of admit in the appendix
that they can't yet make it commercially
viable because it's not ethically
sourced it was largely trained on
copyrighted internet data and yesterday
blockade Labs showcased the add to this
feature where as you can see you can do
Doodles and turn them into images that
go in this 3D World we are swiftly
moving from two Dimensions to three
dimensions and as a bonus this is zip
Nerf a 3D neural rendering Tech released
this week I'm not even counting this as
a third major development I'm lumping it
in with the blockade labs this video
shows what happens when a series of 2
dimensional photographs are merged into
a 3D drone like video and probably a
real estate agent's dream just imagine a
cherished moment in time being
crystallized into a permanent immersive
experience and soon to be honest many
people may not have to imagine with the
Apple reality Pro possibly debuting as
early as June and costing around three
thousand dollars apparently according to
Bloomberg it might be available to buy
in the Autumn and have things like a
dial where you can move between virtual
and augmented reality coming back to
what has already occurred do you
remember when a mid-journey image won
the Colorado State Fair digital art
competition well now the same thing has
happened to photography the
quote-unquote photo on the right was
generated by Dali 2 and it won the 2023
Sony World photography award now the
artist behind it Boris L dagson did
refuse the award I want to show you a
few images that show how far mid-journey
in particular has come over the last
year because many people believe that
mid-journey version 5 is actually
Superior to Dali 2 which won the award
take a look at the progress of the
different mid-journey versions and
remember that version one was released
in February of last year it was almost
exactly one year's difference between V1
and V5 here is another example of the
progress and at this rate we will have
mid-journey version 50 within about 10
years what will that version be like
before I move on to the fourth
development I'm going to show you two of
the craziest images that I could find
from mid Journey version 5. I would say
I can still tell which images are AI
generated around 90 of the time but my
prediction would be that by the end of
the year it will be 90 of the time that
I can't tell if you thought text to
image was getting crazy what about
thought to image or even thought to text
here is a fascinating extra tracked from
the AI dilemma they took human beings
they stuck them into an fmri machine and
they showed them images and they taught
the AI I want you to translate from the
readings of the fmri so how blood is
moving around in your brain to the image
can we reconstruct the image then you
know the AI then only looks at the brain
does not get to see the original image
and it's asked to reconstruct what it
sees so when you dream your visual
cortex sort of runs in Reverse so this
means certainly in the next couple of
years we'll be able to start decoding
dreams okay so it can like see
reconstruct what you're seeing but can
it reconstruct your say what you're
thinking your inner monologue they had
people watch these videos and would try
to reconstruct their inner monologue so
here's the video is this woman getting
hit in the back getting knocked forward
what did the AI reconstruct
I see a girl that looks just like me get
hit on the back and then she's knocked
off the fifth development concerns
something rather more mundane which is
making money now many of you may know
that AI is already well on the way to
conquering poker I used to play a lot of
Poker myself and dare I say I was pretty
darn good at it but even though poker
involves predicting human behavior AI is
starting to master it which brings me
nicely to the development I actually
wanted to talk about which was
forecasting the stock market according
to this really quite interesting paper
accurately forecasting stock market
returns is an emerging capacity of
complex models I'm gonna let the author
of the paper tell you exactly what
prompt they use so the exact question
that we ask is yeah financial advisor
here's a headline is this headline going
to be good or bad for the company in the
short term once you have enough
headlines you basically just invest in
the companies with good headlines and
not invest in the companies with bad
headlines and here is the table
summarizing the results A1 was a
positive headline a negative one was a
negative headline and a zero was a
neutral headline and when gpt3 analyzed
those headlines you can see the
correlation with the average of the next
day's return that's positively
correlated for good headlines according
to Gypsy 3 and negatively correlated for
bad headlines and you can see that
earlier models really couldn't do this
and as many of you may well be thinking
this is gpt3 this is not gpd4 I bet that
as we speak there are thousands of
Traders using the gpt4 API to predict
the next day's stock movements I think
the results will get even more
interesting as the context window
expands and Gypsy 4 or GT5 can analyze
entire articles press conferences Etc
the next development is that fairly
quietly without attracting many
headlines role-playing chat Bots are
beginning to go mainstream character.ai
founded by one of the original author
offers of the Transformer paper recently
crossed a hundred million visitors that
is starting to resemble the growth
trajectory of the original chat GPT gpt4
is still smarter and better at doing
these role plays but the interface of
this site is easy to use and of course
it's free this is not sponsored in any
way but it was pretty fun playing this
text-based adventure game I especially
enjoyed going on complete tangents to
what the adventure was supposed to be
about and I think confusing the AI the
seventh way that we can tell that the
world has fundamentally changed is that
Google doesn't seem all conquering
anymore as it has done for my entire
adult lifetime first I heard in the New
York Times that Samsung was considering
replacing Google with Bing as the
default search engine on its devices I
am not surprised that that shocked
Google employees then yesterday this
article came out in Bloomberg it says
that many Google employees beg their
leadership to not release Bard saying
that it was a path a logical liar and
cringe-worthy I've done videos on that
myself but even when Google employees
tested it out asking it how to land a
plane or do scuba diving the answers it
gave would likely result in serious
injury or death in February one employee
said the following in an internal
message group Bard is worse than useless
please do not launch the concern that
many have is that now Google will ditch
safety in order to catch up as the
article reports these staffers who are
responsible for the safety and ethical
implications of new products have been
told to not get in the way or try to
kill any of the generative AI Tools in
development which brings me to the final
reason that we know we're in the future
the risks of AI Annihilation are
beginning to be taken seriously it's not
just loan voices anymore like Elie Isa
yudkowski who a couple of days ago got a
standing ovation at Ted he believes the
world is firmly on track for AI takeover
it's also other senior figures who
believe our probability of Doom from AI
is non-zero here are some selective
probabilities but I want to focus on
Paul Cristiano who gives a risk of Doom
between 10 and 20 he previously ran the
alignment team at open Ai and now leads
the alignment Research Center and you
may remember them from the gpt4
technical report they were the guys that
open AI trusted to run the model
evaluation of gpt4 testing whether it
could autonomously replicate and gather
resources which they concluded may
become possible with sufficiently
Advanced AI systems but the conclusion
is that the current model is probably
not capable of doing so these are quite
senior figures and insiders giving a
non-trivial risk of AI Annihilation I
think that deserves a lot more public
conversation than it's currently getting
and on that Sam Altman seems to agree
and the bad case and I think this is
like important to say is like lights out
for all of us uh yeah I think it's like
impossible able to overstate the
importance of AI safety and Alignment
work I would like to see much much more
happening so the future is here and I
think the media needs to catch up